hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts be coming here on GPS
navigating your career I'm Julian tired
of Navarre's and I will be a moderator
for today's event they delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by Robertson sponsored by
education grant from blood leaders lab
later is rochas promised to empower
laboratories and people within this this
is accomplished from providing clinical
and strategic insights support and
solution from the industry's top
innovators via loves endures calm the
2016 lab leaders webinar series and
through LP summits our lab leaders live
events we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions right nvm into the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the side window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left this webinar
has been approved for continuing
education credits please click on the CD
button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive the
credits I will now introduce today's
speakers motivating and challenging
individual to excel both professionally
and personally has been the focus of
executive coach n1a 20 plus year career
sharon's wealth of experience includes
working as a trainer and director in the
nonprofit and healthcare sectors owning
and selling a successful business and
for 10 years serving as a director for
global tracking executive search firms
servant help companies sharing is
certified by the Institute for
professional excellence in coaching a
program accredited by the International
coach federation
she is also certified to administer the
Hogan and energy leadership index
assessments Sharon holds a masters of
arts and gerontology and see our
administration from the university of
maryland patrick o'sullivan is currently
the senior director of ancillary
services at florida hospital in orlando
florida florida hospital is one of the
largest medicare providers in the united
states and as part of the advances
health systems he had a degree in
medical technology and a master's degree
in management in addition to a
specialist in blood banking from ascp
patrick spent his career in the
laboratory but was able to hold a
variety of positions ranging from a
bench technologist department manager
elias manager and director of
laboratories he oversaw froze and
construction of his laboratory and help
develop lean processes and automation
throughout the laboratory it was an
address professor at the University of
Central Florida from 2005 to 2014 and
still teaches and lectures frequently
labret and lab would both think Patrick
and Sharons for collaborating to share
their experiences and strategies for all
of our benefit today I will now pass the
presentation over to them Thank You
Julian for your thoughtful introduction
Patrick and I want to thank roche
diagnostics and lab leaders com team for
bringing this important topic your
career development to light and also for
your assistance in helping us prepare
for today and of course thank you to all
the participants for joining patrick and
myself from all over the world to
participate in this webinar most
importantly congratulations for taking
your time out to be on this webinar
you've taken the first step in
navigating your career as a lab leader
you or the person who cares most about
you and the direction your career
journey takes so in today's webinar we
want to help you be proactive and create
a roadmap for your future we're here to
help you apply your well-developed
discovered and research skills to make a
conscious choice to build your career
going to hear from both Patrick in
myself throughout today's webinar but I
have the honor to speak first by sharing
the agenda so let's get started the
agenda includes helping you to first
recognize your key talents and
motivation to build a sustainable and
fulfilling career outline how to look
beyond a linear track for your career
and give some tips tricks and best
practices for creating impactful
business relationships and of course as
Julian mentioned we want you to feel
comfortable asking questions throughout
the webinar I want to start by telling
you a quick story recently I was at a
leadership conference in springfield
massachusetts i had a table where people
came up to me and ask me questions about
their careers there were career changers
of all ages at this workshop working men
and with working women in a variety of
positions in at all leadership level
what was interesting to me was the three
words that I heard most were I don't
know I don't know for example they say I
have some great skills I want to make a
change but don't know I don't want to
make a change but don't know how or I
heard I have a degree in certification
but i don't know what i want to do I
don't know as an executive and career
coach my first responsive get rid of the
words I don't know from your vocabulary
please at best it's a short-term excuse
and at worst it can perpetually hold you
back from realizing your full potential
you are choosing to not take ownership
when you use the words i don't know i
heard expression that i really like it
it's not
what you know it's what you do with what
you know that's what I want to focus
what we want to focus on today focus on
what I do know you know a lot we are all
in a continuous state of learning but
you don't know you can learn through
formal or informal education or by
creating their experiences that's what
we're going to share with you on our
road map today so if to know me is to
know I love clothes and not before said
too many people overvalue what they are
not an undervalue what they are so let's
focus on what you do know again the
seminars interactive so let's take the
time right now to get to know yourself a
little better start fifth start with
tell me let motivate you to get out of
bed and go to work each month each
morning what do you love most about
being in the lab or about working in the
pharmaceutical community take a few
seconds in one word or a couple words
put it in your answers in the queue and
I Q&A box and let's see what we come up
with okay thank you summons potential
answers I'm looking at you love
innovation you love hands-on work you
like to be creative I see somebody who
just loves chemistry I have thank you
performing experiences of experiments
I'm sorry about that I love to have fun
somebody else like intellectual
stimulation public health excellent all
these answers are what are driving us
why do you get up in the morning see if
I have a couple more curiosity is one so
let's move on cell phone
area is the first step in any career
journey so what we're going to do is
have some give you some self-awareness
take away first the suburb what makes
you unique it sounds cliche but you are
your brand it's your personal brand just
like a business you want to be able to
explain what makes you stand out from
the rest what about your personality
your character experiences helps your
employer to recognize your unique
leadership qualities one way to look at
it is what is one word that describes
you at your best understand your why of
course it's important to know what you
do and how you do it but what if others
to believe in you is when you understand
why you want to be in that role or what
makes you the best candidate for the
promotion or a new job what inspires you
because what inspires your look is going
to expire that employee employer to
consider you and then be authentic
authentic is a word that uses a lot now
but what does it mean being authentic
means being genuine if you try to be the
person others want you to be it's not
sustainable it means being comfortable
with yourself and also being comfortable
when you're with yourself when you were
with others you can read more about this
in a book by Amy Cuddy 12 presence which
is a really good tool next assess your
core strength to identify your strengths
ask yourself these questions what are
people come to you for when they need
help what words describe your
personality what are you most confident
doing or what skills can you apply to
your current role and then really
important ask yourself does this align
with what people come to you for we have
when you talk about those questions what
about them were similar for example do
you consider yourself a great problem
solver in your lab and you work really
well under pressure do people often come
to you that help solve their problems
and then the real question is do you
enjoy solving those problems i know
somebody mentioned in the chat box that
that was something they enjoyed if the
answer is yes build on this sometimes
when things come natural to us we gave
them as too easy and we don't realize
how those abilities are natural gifts
are a strength some other strengths
might include being flexible or sure it
is maybe you're somebody who's really
disciplined what are your strengths
another thing to consider is if you're
challenged by a situation do you become
self-critical and then you react and
flee rather than stay the course being
self-aware means recognizing your own
sweet spot or knowing when it's time to
move forward if maybe there's something
you like or to do better it's also
recognizing if there are areas that
maybe you can still develop that's
really important for assessing your
strengths and look at the job
description are you sticking to one job
description or you creating a role
within new job next identify your value
really important people don't often
recognize how important our values are
after the webinar or during the webinar
few you feel like you think that about
it write down what you consider to be
your top three values your values or
your motivators there's your drivers to
perform at your best people don't often
realize that values are the foundation
for our making decisions and enjoy
and being fulfilled at what we do
they're so personal and specific to you
they really represent who you are I've
worked with people who have they listed
ten very important values for them
that's what drives them those values
they want them to be recognized in the
course of their day and then there are
others who have three very distinct
values that they know they need to have
satisfied whether it be their families
or helping others or being challenged on
the job all those would be some values
what we don't often recognize is how
important it is that your personal
values are line with the company values
for example if your values aren't
aligned with the culture or the people
you're not going to be motivated to do
the job you know you might not realize
what's bugging you you might not be able
to define it it just no it's not working
if that's the chain reassess look at
what values drive you I'll give you an
example of how values can make a
difference on the job perhaps you
started in the lab because you loved a
job that's hands-on and you're not
somebody who likes to work in a
traditional office setting maybe you
love science and want to make
discoveries but your family situation
has changed and you need to prioritize
differently and can no longer work the
night shift another situation that your
values may get involved is you've been
working more as a solopreneur somebody
who really does their job independently
and being part of a team is important to
you that's another value you have to
look at your environment what is it
energizing you and what's taking away
that energy perhaps lab testing is still
something you love doing
how can you expand on that and that's
what we're going to be talking about
with the different ideas in today's
webinar your tours values don't tend to
change over time but you might find that
you prioritize them differently or you
might find in different situations you
recognize different values so again with
self-awareness identify your interest
and your passion a passion is something
that really interests you when you when
you're passionate about something it
gives you a really rewarding feeling it
makes you want to investigate further it
intrigues you it's likely to be
something you would do even if you are
getting paid for it so if you love the
discovery you're probably somebody who's
curious in the lab and outside of the
lab ultimately you want to make sure
that you keep interested and challenged
in order to engage your career in the
long haul so ask yourself what do you
enjoy most about your job look at your
resume look at your job description and
see how you can answer that question
what is he what interests you most in
those areas and what areas do you still
want to learn more about the question
came up for me recently what's the
difference between our values and our
passions sometimes they're similar but
our values often initiate from our
upbringing there are poor beliefs and
that's whether it drives us whereas our
passion are truly our interests they
write our fire you know when you're in
that zone that you're leading your
passion and passion is contagious your
employer will feel it from you if you're
a leader or you have direct report your
direct reports will feel your passion
the desire to really do a great job
and finally learn and tell your story
keeper learn through stories and that's
why it's so great today that we have
Patrick to tell his story what did you
do before let's change what can you
learn from your past experiences and
this is something people don't often
think to do what patterns or theme have
come up in your own personal story is
there somebody who can help you observe
the change or that you've observed
change themselves maybe that's somebody
you can emulate and telling stories I
want to cast them one now to Patrick
it's a perfect time for patrick
o'sullivan to share first-hand his story
and how he grew and manifested his
career with unexpected opportunities go
ahead Patrick Sharon thank you for
passing the baton to me and again I want
to reiterate that really appreciate
everybody's attendance today so we're
going to go way back in time maybe
before some of you were born but I
started my career professionally as a
medical technologist back in 1981 so at
the time I graduated college and started
my first job at the hospital and had
opportunity to work as a generalist for
a little while and then kind of migrated
to blood banking and I like blood
banking because it was a passion of mine
so Sharon was just talking about passion
so where I migrated into is where I felt
really comfortable and I saw in your
comments earlier how many of you are
passionate about your job and that you
like to come to work you like the people
you like the science of it I like the
science of it which really drove me into
this career so I started working and you
know come to work every day and do job
and you know produce results and when I
was in blood bank produced watch blood
cells and things like that but as I got
on in a couple years later I said I want
to do I want to make a difference
you know the next step I want to take is
I want to make a difference so I thought
to myself well how do I make a
difference and and and you'll see
throughout my career you ask questions
and the question may have a different
response at different times but it at
that moment in time when I was when I
was young and I still considered myself
young today that I said I need some more
education I look to get the specialty in
blood banking for example and then I
thought about a little bit about you
know looking at other job opportunities
so I was young and had an opportunity to
be a director of an outreach program and
I went for that put in my application
everything and I didn't get it but it
was always an experience to try for
different jobs and different things that
kind of stretch what you do and I was
fortunate enough after five years to get
a job as the blood bank manager and this
starts my career of what I'll call the
five-year plan so as we talk today
you're going to find about every five
years I put on a different hat and and
it's important to know how you got to
that different hat in there but my first
learning that was important is you go
from a task-oriented job as you do tasks
of the day I wanted to make a difference
and I move to a job that now requires
leadership and it's something which i
haven't had experience in so now you'll
see as we continue the story and Sharon
continues her things how you make that
leap from management to being a leader
Sharon I'll turn it back over to you
thanks so much Patrick I appreciate that
and that really goes into this next
section really well love me to take a
few seconds that respond how he was
defining in a sense how he was defining
his journey in his own self awareness
take a few seconds and think about how
do you define success go ahead and put
it in the Q&A box did you measure
success for yourself
see some of the answers we have here so
I see some people are saying that
success is about growth it's about
owning their own home it's about having
a title on the job or being a subject
matter expert so what you find is
success is different for everybody
however it starts typically with the
same place it starts with having a
courageous mindset courage precision
equal success I was recently at a
conference and I got this formula
actually from Marlee Matlin I don't know
if you guys are familiar with her Marlee
Matlin is a celebrity and guest actress
she won an Oscar it I think she was aged
19 at the first deaf actress and she
said this is what got her to do what she
was told she could never do what is
courage Persian doing something even
when it seems impossible or frightening
when you start with courage confidence
follows people often feel like you have
to have confidence first but truly it's
about courage it means getting out of
your comfort zone without going into
your panic zone I love that you know
they get we get worried it's about
taking chances without worrying about
the mistake but rather learning from
them so for example we just talked about
skills how might you stretch your skill
well what would you do differently then
add vision take the time and write a
vision statement for yourself what do
you want your life to look like five
years from now three years or even one
year and then actually write that vision
down reverse engineer it create your own
action steps so that you can realize
that dream more often than why your path
to career success look more like a
jungle gym than it does a
matter I love that expression because we
often think that were on a linear path
and we're here to tell you today and I
think projects the perfect example that
it doesn't have one approach there are
many ways to realize your vision and
here's Patrick again to talk a little
bit about his story his jungle gym story
aquiline so now we're going to fast
forward another five years in my career
and as manager of our transfusion
services for five years and then an
opportunity came up to be a data
processing coordinator now mind you this
is still 1990 ish and we hadn't got to
use the word information systems yet but
there was this data processing
coordinator which translates into a
laboratory information systems manager
of today's world and I looked at that
job and it was intriguing to me you know
i was like computers for those of you
who were old enough to remember had a
comet over 64 at home and lots of
horsepower in that machine but what I
did was this job intrigued me I thought
wow I know nothing about it nothing what
it entails so I ended up going to the
person who had that job and I said what
do you do you know I have no do and it
sounded very interesting to me and it
wasn't part of my comfort zone and
Sharon talks about being in your comfort
zone it was totally foreign from what I
did I mean you didn't shake tubes to run
the computer so I decided to apply for
the job and I got the job and it was a
very different job being a manager of
people and processes it was easy to
direct but now I was only the manager of
a computer and maybe it was good it
didn't talk back to me most of the time
anyway but I learned to work with other
people who certainly had more
understanding of programming and
computer sciences than i had and i began
to work towards learning what they did
and i found a very important lesson in
this part of my career
was leading work through other people so
instead of being the manager of people I
needed to work with other people and it
was a skill that again I had to learn
and I had to get better at as time went
on so as this phase of my career went I
always learned to work with other people
and the results that I produced were for
the common good of everyone so the
better the computer system was the more
functionality it has the better programs
we had the better training that I did it
helped out everyone so it's a different
fulfillment that I had from the
beginning in my career Sharon back to
you thank you so much and I love that
because that's the perfect transition I
love what you said when you said you
didn't know about computer programming
there are people who knew more than you
but you were willing to explore and the
transition is perfectly the same you
don't know what you don't know but you
can get answers you can learn from
others so how can you identify other
opportunities for example you might
think that the next steps if you're
working in the lab or to be the manager
or the director but you you don't know
where to go from there or if there are
other options maybe for you managing
doesn't excite you but you actually love
data collection that portion of your
work so you can explore opportunities
and speak to people for working as data
analyst or gathering big data which is a
big area today in pharma work maybe
you'll of operations and recognize that
in order to get further you want to get
yourself a business degree so you can
excel in the operations arena in the
pharmaceutical industry that's great
it's thinking outside the box and
recognizing you don't have to have all
the answers a really great thing to do
is go on linkedin look at profiles of
people who have worked in labs see what
their career trajectory look like you're
going to find all different stories
and different ways and different paths
you might even learn something that you
didn't know existed a job or a job
opportunity or career opportunity i
should say then create a list of people
you admire it could be a professor it
could be your current or a previous blog
it could be up here what is they doing
and what knowledge can you learn from
them investing in your learning is so
important another way to do that and
speaking to people I'm not sure how many
of you are familiar with the term
informational interviews I like to call
it an informational conversation it's
really just a meeting with you as
somebody who's either seeking a job or
looking to excel accelerate your career
or transform your career meets with
somebody in either a job field a
different company and ask them questions
about real life experiences similar to
what Patrick is sharing with you today
talk to more people because what he has
to offer is so valuable find more people
when you invest in your learning I like
the expression and no expression is just
in time learning versus just one time
learning in my day you go to school you
get your degree and unless you have
specific career is like in medicine as a
doctor you didn't necessarily have to
continue but that's not true anymore
it's really important for you to
recognize that learning has to be
continuous all of you who are on this
webinar or right in there I give you a
lot of credit because you're recognizing
that there are opportunities listen to
more of the wild rivers calm webinars
read the white papers that come out look
at other resources research trends in
your industry or look at association
join linkedin groups and see what they
have to share surround yourself with
others
we'll help you grow think about it who
influences you most in your career you
know whose opinion matters to you I what
patrick said these work with others
instead of leaving others from the top
how can you find peers find colleagues
who's your boss is Pierre what might
they be able to share with you you might
be your next boss what other departments
could you be inquiring about so I'm
going to let Patrick tell you how he
leveraged learning and stepping up into
his career in this next chapter go ahead
Patrick so one of the things that I
learned early is that is you don't know
everything but you can find out lots of
stuff by talking to people and by
encouraging yourself to learn so how do
you learn so back in 1991 I decided to
go for my masters and I wanted to take
my master's degree I looked at what was
out there and I decided to get a masters
degree in management and one of the
first classes i had was finance or
accounting I'm sorry and I never had
accounting before you know it came from
this strict science background and
numbers weren't part of that and took
the class and actually struggled a
little bit in it and then I got into it
and then we had financed and things like
that and I really like that and as I
look back across my career that that
accounting that finance that I had as
part of my master's degree has helped me
out tremendously and I was telling
somebody this morning how much I love
numbers and data analytics and stuff so
that's one way to learn is through
professional learning but the other way
is to through professional associations
you got to get out there and get
involved so nobody's going to come to
you and offer you a different job or an
opportunity necessarily you've got to
create experience for yourself so what I
did was became part of professional
organizations so the clinical lab
manager says so
ascp i would go to aacc user groups for
information systems was quite useful for
me to meet other people and to get to
know people and through those
associations and through starting to
know people and becoming part of
professional organizations I got to go
places how many of you go to a trip to a
convention or anything do you take the
time to visit a hospital another health
care institution another laboratory do
you take the time to be a CA p inspector
for example which can get you throughout
the world and see what other people do
and when you're out there in visiting
other places you want to do you want to
talk to people and I want to call this
purposeful talking is not how are you
today or whatever is asked them about
their job you know what if you have a
particular challenge ask them how do you
solve the staffing issue or how do you
solve a technical issue listen to them
see observe know what other people do
you can learn a lot from having
purposeful conversations with many many
people and one of the things Sharon will
tell you is to develop this set of
people that you can go back to and ask
questions throughout your career I
remember meeting a pathologist at a cma
meeting and we came across each other
again at a computer user group meeting
and then we came across each other again
it at ascp and through the years we
developed a relationship and it was able
to learn from him about how his lopper
asians were all the way in california
even though i was here in florida the
other thing is take opportunity when you
get it to teach and I taught 10 years at
the at the University of Central Florida
teaching keeps you current and it allows
you to take that information and
formulate it in such a way as you can
tell other people about it and as you
teach you learn yourself so I encourage
you to take opportunity to teach things
even it is something you do every day
and every once in a while teach
something that
you don't know anything about and do all
the research for that chance that's
great and I have to tell you Patrick in
that vein I just started teaching at a
college for the same reason so I'm
heating your advice and I totally concur
with that as well so tips tricks and
best practices what are the top five
tips that we can give you there's so
many different things we're learning
today but we're going to try to narrow
it down and I'm going to build upon what
Patrick just said being good at what you
do is not enough to get you to the next
level you have to be aware of your
surroundings you have to be aware of how
you can work with people and and
diagnostics at a bigger level but it's
about being connected Patrick just
mentioned how over the years you might
see people at the same conference think
about start before you need it
networking I sometimes suggest when
someone gets a new jobs the first thing
they do is meet someone you and your
company every day people are expecting
you to introduce yourself even if you're
somewhere quiet or shy you have this
open door to just say hi on knew I'd
like to introduce myself if you're not
comfortable with that then if somebody
else is willing to introduce you find a
colleague or your boss or appear that
you'll be working with and have them
take you around to introduce you to
different people sometimes we just go to
our case so quickly that we forget to
say hello or it was someone new at lunch
and introduce yourself in the cafeteria
look at what you're doing be curious
curiosity is all part of the learning
process I challenge one of my Cochise
wants to set a goal to meet two new
people every week on the job some
companies aren't that big other
companies are larger
it doesn't just have to be in your
company that you're moving to new people
but make that your goal you can even
tell somebody I have a boldly to new
people a week and they be flattered that
you selected them as one of the people
to meet once again we said don't stay in
house speak to people on other hospitals
other companies you can talk to people
the pharmaceutical sales rep who are
selling to your department speak to
other technicians everybody has
something you can learn even if that's
not something you wish to do it's a new
connection and it's a new opportunity
when you start learning as patrick said
even teaching you continue to be a
valuable contributor to your
organization and you're growing at the
same time for those that you've been
working for a long time of the company
you can start now it's never too late
build relationships you don't want to
work in a silo you don't want to just
keep your head down and get your work
done so show genuine interest in people
make sure when you show general genuine
interest you're listening you're making
eye contact you're making them feel good
you can also use LinkedIn premium for
those of you are not familiar with it
you can get it for 30 days free so go on
that site and sometimes people don't
realize networking is not just industry
but it can also be socializing outside
when you're liking what you do relief
people find a mentor be a mentor I love
that expression if you're a message to
somebody else rightly law of attraction
somebody will come and mentor you but by
people that you know don't don't them
don't assume that someone is not there
to support you ask asking is sometimes
the most important tool I know somebody
who started a program and maybe you can
start a mentorship program in your
company they called it three cups of
coffee and
all it took and then create your own
personal Board of Directors just as
Patrick just mentioned who is your
personal board of directors they're
people that you trust who can support
you in your development vision be senior
professional this would be champions in
your industry they can be brought they
can be friends I know somebody who told
me Oprah was on her board of directors
did she know it no but it's people that
you can look to for information yes it's
ideal to have a diverse group of people
that can guide and inspire you and give
you advice and the ones who do know
they're on your board of directors ask
them tell them that you want feedback or
what i like to call feed-forward so they
can speak to you straight up and tell
you how you're showing up and then give
back teaching is a great way to give
back sharing articles blog post or write
articles so that you can be seen as a
leader in your field it's so much easier
today with the internet and what I like
to say is focus on re not the whistle
what's with them what's in it for me
think about what you're giving and
Patrick so I had your on what are some
real life experiences you want to
mention so the neck next phase is in my
career were actually again sticking with
the five-year plan so after first being
the data processing coordinator who
actually builds a department for
laboratory information systems which I
became manager of so I did that for
about five years and really started to
expand knowledge in total hospital
laboratory operations sometimes the path
you're in allows you to see the outside
a little bit so being as part of the
computer system I was able to see how
the computer system affected all areas
of lab things I didn't know about at one
point in my career even though as a
medical
just I helped write the psychology
database and the cytology manager was
teaching me about cytology so I got to
learn new things in actually doing work
with the computer systems opportunity
again arose to be assistant director of
laboratories and direct operations of
about half of our laboratory departments
there again an area that I didn't some
areas that I wasn't totally familiar
with but you take the leap and you start
to focus your energies on areas that you
don't know about again talking to people
reading different magazines different
publications and one of the things i do
believe totally in reading there's a lot
of publications out there and if you
teach you let your students read them
and do reports back to you that's one
way to learn quicker but but you want to
learn and read as assistant the director
for about five years and then moved on
to be the director of the laboratories
again a whole new world and a larger
operation so you're just growing in what
you know but as time went by started
looking at health care in a different
way looking beyond the walls of the
laboratory looking beyond the walls of
the hospital understanding about the
community of health care and as I began
to look in this I became very interested
in hospital operations you know how do
you run a hospital versus running a lab
what things are important in the lab we
tend to deal with the test tubes and
specimens out there in the hospital you
deal with patients and you deal with
people's lives no matter what you do but
you when you get closer to it it means a
different things so opportunity again
came up for me a couple years ago to be
a director of ancillary systems again
areas I didn't know anything about I
didn't know about respiratory therapy I
didn't know about rehabilitation
services so again talk to those people
one of the first things I did was go to
a seminar in rehabilitation and really
started to understand what they do and
then you learn from people one is to
talk to mentors like Sharon is talking
about
the second thing is to talk to people if
you go into a job where you are not
familiar with the work talk to the
people that do the work and I found
rounding with the staff members a great
value to understanding how people do
work what they do what their job is and
then as you're their senior leader you
can understand what they do so they
don't talk to you so you've got to
continue to learn continue to talk and
really reach out and find out new
information and leverage those learnings
so that as you move on or move over
which is not a bad thing and do
different things in your life that
you're able to see the whole picture
Sharon thank you so much and so make a
commitment to yourself that's really
what Patrick is saying what I love you
said is he didn't know about a lot of
things but he said yes opportunities
came and he said yes write down your
commitment and make a contract with
yourself what you want to do doesn't
just happen you have to be purposeful so
there's some quick tips show grit grit
is resilience and the ability to stay
committed to your goal either one
challenge that actionable goals because
that's where confidence comes in and
achieve them do something for your
career every day even if it's just 10 to
15 minutes and make sure you're part of
the plan and not just part of the
company's work every day focus on the
process and not the result you want to
take the long view what's your legacy
doesn't be and the short view next week
next month how are you working on your
prioritizing your career and I mentioned
it before and I'll mention it again Amy
Cuddy I mentioned her Brooke earlier and
I saw somebody asked the book is present
and what she says in that book is fake
it till you become it going for it it
doesn't mean you're not genuine or
expensive but it means you have the
courage to be yourself
so that you can excel and takes a career
and weak job choices as i mentioned i
love quotes and here's another one we
spoke about success before and i have to
say some more came in on success people
said success is about improving lives
accomplishing roles making patient lives
better success is not the cue to
happiness happiness is the key to
success so when you're looking at
navigating your career what makes you
happy that's what all this
self-awareness journey is about and on
that I want to have Patrick have the
last word until we have question and
answer Patrick you're on Sharon I really
just want to repeat a little bit what
you said and as you look back as you as
you do things in your life I really
think it's important to be purposeful
and often I say to people that work for
me it's you know a lot of times you say
oh I appreciate your hard work or work
hard or whatever but actually what I
appreciate is purposeful work yes you
understand why you're doing the work
what you're doing it for and the same
thing goes about your career as you look
to say hey I want to do something
different I want to I want to expand
opportunities maybe you want to make
more money maybe you want to be happy at
doing something different you can need
to be purposeful about it it's not going
to happen by accident it's not going to
happen by you sitting in a chair it's
going to happen by you going out and
talking to people by taking a chance of
going into the unknown in doing
something that you haven't done before
and learning about it and becoming good
at it and then looking for your next
opportunities so I just I just have to
repeat what Sharon said go for it and
just do it so anyway on my behalf I want
to thank you guys for listening and I
think we turn it back over to the
moderator at this point
yes thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you could submit
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can our
first question can you provide thoughts
on the following I uncover new role I'm
interested in but it doesn't fully align
with what I recognize as my core
strength but would you recommend is my
next step so I'll answer that Jen every
time you go into a new job there are
going to be new strengths that you have
to align with I think Patrick mentioned
it when he said he knew nothing about
some of the areas that he was tackling
and it turns up he went to seminars to
learn so I guess the question I have for
you are these areas that you absolutely
are not interested in or is it that
you're fearful or that you don't
currently have those shrinks because if
you don't have them then there are ways
to get them and learn and I think the
first step is speaking to others to see
what it is you need speak with your boss
and find out how you might be able to
develop those skills within the current
role that you are and then when we talk
about alignment I often think the
difference between aligning our strength
versus our values your values are that
core belief if your values aren't
aligned you're going to be thrown off
energetically it's not going to feel
right but strengths are skills that can
be developed hope that answers that
question the next question do you need
to formally ask someone to be a part of
your board of directors or make sure if
so what does that look like ah I will go
ahead with this and say you need to
formally ask somebody
think when I use the visual or Oprah I
don't think that person was at but I do
think that um you do want a core group
of people that you want to say i really
respect you i really trust your drawers
and you're going to give me honest
feedback as to how i can grow and as i
said each of these family members it can
be a boss it can be a colleague or you
find a mentor and say to them I'd love
to be on my board of directors it
doesn't mean that you're going to have
formal meetings but what you do want to
do is make sure you have consistent
touch-based time with them or follow-up
time with them if it's somebody that
you're just using as an example for you
to emulate that's a different story that
might be a person that you read articles
that they've written or you look at
their career trajectory and we try to
emulate or aspire to that position so
that's how funny thank you how do you
navigate looking for your next role if
you define success in your current job
differently than your immediate
supervisor I'll take this one is Patrick
it's very interesting I had a I believe
when you work for somebody your job is
to work for them and do what they need
to do the success if you were in their
job what you would do might be different
so I think you really have to step back
a little bit and say okay I'm in a job
and I have a manager or somebody who I'm
working for and you need to fulfill that
role when you look for a different role
you may want to do something different
and that's okay so there's one thing to
say when I go to the next role I'll do
something different the other thing too
is to keep in mind that sometimes you
want to talk to your management mint
about leadership like what does
leadership mean for you what is
leadership mean to them we often don't
take enough time to talk to the people
we work for about how we lead one
another
we're being led and it's a lot but often
open up a interesting conversation the
next question Sharon you mentioned a
book in the beginning of the
presentation can you please ream ention
the title of that book sure and it's her
name is Amy Cuddy si UD deen wide and
the book is called presence and it's
about how you can present yourself she
also has a very good TED talk that to
listen to and the TED talk is all about
body language and presentation so I
highly recommend both of those next
everyone has their personal code of how
people should be introduced depending on
where they are in the epidemic hierarchy
what if that's not working for you
hiding connections besides blinken and
at conferences do you want to take that
Patrick or you want me to take that sure
I'll go ahead and answer that um I was
looking at this question trying to
figure out exactly how we want to answer
that but the idea is talk to anybody and
everybody and if they don't want to talk
to you then maybe they're not worth
talking to I do believe conferences are
a great place to talk to people because
most people want to talk there and a lot
of people are there to learn from others
so there are people always out there
that you want to talk to talk to people
in other areas of your institution if
you're in the laboratory it's okay to
talk to people who are in nursing or in
respiratory therapy or even
environmental services and nutritional
services it's amazing what you can learn
from people that do things in different
areas I was in a project once where we
looked at nutritional services and found
out it's in many ways
production-oriented like lab is so
literally there's lots of people to talk
to if they don't want to talk to you a
move on because maybe they don't have
anything to share so just that's my
quick way of answering that one great
the next question how do you learn some
people if they're not open to talking to
you about what they do that's a limiting
belief start with I can have a more
specific example would be helpful as a
coach I would say remove that limiting
belief first and if one person to talk
to you doesn't mean everybody feels the
same way so you keep trying I think
Patrick just didn't the last question as
well find somebody else to speak to or
if you're coming from a place of always
asking versus giving what might you be
able to give back if you know if you do
for example just know a leader in your
industry how are you showing up would
you can you share an article that you
found that might be of interest that
person and use that as a segue
particularly when you're reaching out on
linkedin I often suggest to people if
what we're having done the research gaps
might you be able to fill or aunt
questions you can answer for somebody
else we go back to you do know where you
guys are researchers find answers to
help other people as well the next
election is no Patrick are you then yes
okay Perpetua currently most shadow
advertisements needs here to expert
people how did you get into the job
swear you're not an expert in it well
first of all don't assume you're not
senior or you're not an expert in it if
you're at the level where you place job
applications you're always looking for
somebody with experience and certain
knowledge
but the people who apply may or may not
have it so don't sell yourself short
always apply for something even if it's
a stretch it's good to learn about what
that job is and about it so if we go
back to my story when I got the job in
computers I didn't know anything about
it at all and that's where you start to
talk people or you start to read books
you start to make yourself knowledgeable
you will often learn a lot when you
don't get a job I had an opportunity in
my career to apply for a vice-president
job that I didn't get but it gave me an
hour with the CEO of the hospital that I
never would have had if I hadn't gone
for that job and it provided me with
insight on what I would need and what
skills I would need to move up the
ladder for that so my advice is go for
it and you never know what people are
looking for and I tell my students at
the University like I don't have
experience I'm like yes you do you've
done this you've had your internship
you've had your training I said you have
more experience than you think you have
so don't tell you should sell yourself
short don't forward please so
unfortunately we don't have any more
time for any more questions today we
would like to thank lab leaders from
making today's webcast possible the
dedicated discussion guide will be
available with on-demand access to this
webcast on the webinars page of lab
leaders calm within the next week you
will receive an email from libraries
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
follow that announcement to your
colleagues Mavis today's live events you
will also find use of the next
installment of the lab leaders webinar
series and have the ability to watch
many more on the man ensure your
registered on lab leaders are
comfortable access today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing until
December 2016 thank you and goodbye